تطورات تقنيه الذكاء الاصطناعي عم تبهر
البشريه يوم بعد يوم والجديد بخبرنا عن
الذكاء الاصطناعي هو روبوت محامي بيستعد
دخول المحاكم لاول مره في التاريخ ايمتى
الشهر المقبل فاعلن الرئيس التنفيذي لشركه
دونات بلاي عن او دونات بي عفوا عن روبوت
هو الاول من نوعه راح يدخل يدافع عن متهم
في محكمه في فبراير وطريقه عمله رح تكون
عبر الهاتف الذكي فالروب والترح يستمع الى
الاقوال والشهادات ومجريات المحاكمه عابر
سماعه بلوتوث ومن بعدها راح يصير ردود
المناسبه ويدافع عن المدعي عليه مش عارفه
اذا بكون في حدا عم بلقنه واللي هو من
حاله عماله درس قانوني يعني مش عارفه على
كل حال السبب الاساسي الاستغلال
التكنولوجيا هو تخفيف التكاليف عنها كثير
من الناس
احم عفوا اللي ما بيقدروا يتحملوا تكاليف
المحاماه العاليه وللفت في هاي تكنولوجيا
انه في حال خساره المحامي الروبوت الدعوه
الدعوه او الشركه بتدفع اي غرامات
وبتترتب هاي الغرامات يعني على المدعي
عليه